hello dr. Berg here in this video we're
going to talk about if your knees are
bone on bone and you have no more
cartilage left and let's say you're not
excited about getting surgery you want
to postpone it as long as possible we're
going to talk about some possible
solutions now it's kind of a catch-22
because here you are you might be
overweight and you need to go exercise
but you can't because your knees are
killing you so you can't lose weight so
here you're stuck between a rock and
hard place so what are you gonna do
there's about three things you should do
number one you want to get your knees
symmetrical so many people have an out
of balance situation between their left
leg and their right leg and I'm talking
about a little slightly longer leg which
then puts pressure on the knees okay
throws everything off if you can get
your knees totally symmetrical when you
walk and there's no imbalance you can
reduce the tension and stress on the
knee joints considerably and some people
don't even need to get surgery I'm gonna
put a link down for a separate complete
video on that but I'll tell you in a
thumbnail sketch just a brief thing on
it the mistake that that most people
make is that they look at the bottom of
your leg lengths okay and like there's
one short leg like let's say of a short
leg and they give you a heel lift to
make this balance right it's a big
mistake because usually the reason why
that leg is short is because the hip is
higher on the short leg okay so the leg
isn't shirt at all it's just a high hip
your hip is higher at one side and your
spine is crooked so if we put a heel
lift in the short leg we drive the high
hip higher worsening the symmetry of the
left and right side of your lower part
of your body so you want to go by your
hip your hips you can get an x-ray or
just have someone eyeball it you know
with your belt or your your where your
pants goes across you want to go by the
hip and so let's say for example you
look at the hip in the left side of your
hip is dropped down
you would want to put the heel lift in
the longer leg okay like a little a
little lift in your shoe I've done that
with people and it's just take all their
knee pains all it just completely goes
away just by balancing the leg okay it's
really a pelvis problem they fell on the
butt bone on one side a long time ago
and ever since then it's been out of
whack so that's step one I put another
put a link down below on a complete
video on how to correct that okay number
two there's some really great
acupressure things that you can do for
the for knee pain in general I'm gonna
put another complete video down below
but if you have pain on one joint only
okay and not on the other one you would
want to work on the opposite side on the
muscles higher up I put a video down
below a link so you can see what I'm
talking about
but this is if you just have one knee
that's hurting okay but you might have
both of your knees hurting so you
wouldn't need to watch that but the
point is if it's just one side you need
to watch this video that will help you
considerably because if we could just
take and balance your your knees doing
acupressure that will take the pain
right down okay
third thing reducing inflammation
because if you have bone and bone you
probably have a lot of inflammation in
your knees and we need to get rid of
that before you start exercising or
walking or anything like that now
typically what happens people that have
bone on bone have a lot of extra weight
that they need to lose okay I'm assuming
you do you might not but if you do
you're in luck because the best thing to
do would be to do a program that fixes
something called insulin resistance okay
so insulin resistance is the number one
cause of higher levels of insulin that
causes belly fat ass tuck metabolism so
if you were to fix this going an eating
plan to fix this that would bring your
inflammation way down it's dramatic it's
powerful and you have if you have bone
and bone you need to do this it you
might be in a situation where you could
reduce all the inflammation and pain and
you know you a bun and bone you're
walking around and you're fine you have
no more pain that happens all the time
especially with inflammation okay and
swelling and then you'll lose weight to
eighty-five percent of a person's weight
can be handled with eating fifteen
percent is exercise okay so we don't
have to do the exercise right now anyway
so what you want to do is in real a
summary form and then I'll put some
links down below you want to start with
three meals no snacks okay
why that's in a minute fasting so to go
from one meal to the next you have to
add a little bit of healthy fat so
you're not as hungry
the snacking in between the meals and
the snacking at night is gonna really
destroy everything the small five meals
a day or six meals a day has to go you
want three meals that's it
okay you want to have a lot of greens
and vegetables because that has the
vitamin C to help build up hormones that
are anti-inflammatory all the hormones
that are anti-inflammatory there are the
adrenal gland hormones need vitamin C as
a precursor so you need to consume a lot
of vegetables and some protein small
amount and actually higher amounts of
healthy fat at the meal so you start off
three and you do that for a period of
time and then when you get used to that
you want to go two meals a day don't eat
in the morning go all the way until
lunch and then have your dinner so you
have two meals a day and now you have
from dinner all the way to the next
lunch of not eating to heal the insulin
problem because insulin is triggered
when you eat so if we could take all the
stress out of insulin inflammation comes
way down and you no longer hurt in your
knees and you can postpone the surgery
okay so add a lot of vegetables there's
one other thing that you may want to
check out too I have a a joint support
formula that has in it not just the
standard things like glucosamine and
things like that but it has in there
adrenal extracts such as support the
adrenal it has in there some serious
natural food complexes of vitamin C it
has
they're some herbs that are
anti-inflammatory like stinging nettle
root which are very powerful so I put a
link down before down below you can
check it out and get more information
but those are the things that you need
to do if you have bone and bone and you
want to postpone surgery as long as
possible thanks for watching hi guys hey
listen I created a pretty amazing
evaluation quiz down below that actually
analyzes your symptoms to find the cause
the root cause of all of your symptoms
the most likely cause
so take the quiz now and we'll send you
a report